>>Cathrine: Can somebody read
that learning target for me?
>>Student: I can participate wholly and
mindfully in my book club discussion.
>>Dr Cantor: When teachers
enable choice, they're setting
in motion a child's ability to
direct interest towards something
that matters to them.
If we can capitalize on the
interests that a child has,
what we've done is taken some of
the difficulty out of learning it.
>>Student: In my book, I Am Malala,
their city that they live in is in war.
>>Dr Cantor: We want students to
push their developmental range.
We don't want them to shut
down and be discouraged,
but at the same time we want to push
them to the greatest level of challenge
that they can do with confidence.
>>Cathrine: Oh, book
choice is everything
for getting a lot of kids to read.
>>Student: In my book, Does My Head
Look Big in This, people have started
to accept Amal for her
choice to wear the hijab.
>>Cathrine: I give them about ten
different books to choose from.
I tried to include different themes
that I thought would resonate.
When they choose their book,
we use a protocol called PICK.
The P is whether they
understand the book's purpose.
The I is to reflect on their
interest level in the book's topic.
The C is comprehension.
If they open it up and read a passage,
do they remember what they read?
That shows comprehension.
The K is for do they know the words.
When they read, are there more than
five words that they don't know?
That book is too hard.
So we go through the PICK process for
students to choose a book that they like
but also is at their reading level.
>>Dr Cantor: Their choice of a
book can give a teacher a sense
of where they feel competent, and
also give the teacher insights
about where it would be
important to push them.
>>Teacher: I feel like it's a
good way to get to know them,
and it's a good way to
know how they're doing.
In addition to that, it gives
me a look inside of their minds.
Being able to choose your own book
means that that book is special to you,
and you take it home and
it feels like your friend,
if you've chosen it yourself.